thank you thank you for coming
Tina kind of oversold me but hopefully
not too much because I believe the
wattage is very important this is my
battle cry these days
failure bites bite back I'm a serial
entrepreneur and I kind of got my butt
kicked a few times and the last time I
decided I don't want this to ever happen
again
to me or anyone else so my mission is to
help entrepreneurs most of you here to
teach you how to fight failure and win
consistently but first let me tell you
I'm gonna structure it very simply seven
strategies in 35 minutes I don't have a
lot of time but fortunately there is a
book that you can buy out there that you
know you can spend six hours in my
company and also give you give the
advice you would give to your 20 year
old self so a lot of 20 year old here
but regardless this advice is timeless
so that whether you're 20 30 40 50 60
this entrepreneurial advice is
applicable now my intrapreneurial
journey as you can tell from accent I
was not born here I was born in Italy
and like pizza I decided to come from
Italy to America for bigger and and
better things
and of course what you do so I landed in
Silicon Valley I decided I want to join
a startup and I join in 1985 a little
startup called Sun Microsystems pre pre
pre IPO and some of you are too young
you don't even know about this company
but used to be kind of like the Google
of those days and had a very good run
there for about 13 II thirteen years I
was an engineering at the at first and
then I and running ended up running a
research group and the stock went great
and so I thought wow this is so cool
you know startups are great this is
awesome I want to do my old startup so I
left Sun and I started my first company
will raise three million dollars in VC
funding and eighteen months later we
received an offer for acquisition for
100 million dollars do you think we
accepted that offer how many think you
were accepted no but are you full yeah
of course we accepted it
you accepted it you know this was 2001
that's like a billion today don't be an
idiot take it right take it so it worked
out very well and I thought well you
know this is easy so as I thought well
call my friends in Italy a Mario come to
America it's good you know this is and
so I spent a year at the acquiring
company and then I joined another little
startup pre preappeal called Google as
the first engineering director and you
know among other things I led the ad
steam and we'll know how well Google did
so I thought you know this is really
easy and I'm kind of good at picking
startups so if I raise three million
dollars and exited with a hundred
million dollar offer for its 30 million
dollars I'm gonna exit at 1 billion you
know the math doesn't really work like
that but you know in in my mind that
sounded good so my second my second
startup which I founded where is 25
million dollars from the best pieces in
the valley we developed this tool that
people told us if you can build this
software development tools
everybody will flock to your doors
please build it and we will buy it so we
built the tool spend two years to build
a very sophisticated product every we
want every possible awards for
technology was an amazing - so I thought
wow I'm really good at this you know and
I maybe the Italian Steve Jobs Stefano
Stefano Joe beanie you know that sounds
good it has a ring to it
except that five years later bang we
know we had a fire sale all those people
that told us if you build it we will buy
somehow disappeared even though we built
exactly what they said we were going to
build so this time our reaction was a
little different and I created this
acronym that stands for why the failure
right so I I asked myself why did we why
did we fail and I decided okay I want to
study failure so I went back to Google
as engineering director but also as
innovation agitator to try to shake new
new ideas out of Google and you cannot
innovate without failure and failing so
I became from an engineer I became an
innovation agitator and always wanted a
PhD and I didn't get it but I got an F D
I'm a doctor of philosophy the only one
in the world
I don't know if anybody in the planet
has studied failure more than I did and
I'm here to share with you some of this
idea so I only have time to give you
seven strategy started with ten and then
I timed it and I couldn't do it so I
decided Alberto you're gonna talk fast
and you're only gonna give them seven
strategies first one obey the law of
market failure the law comes in two
parts the first one is pretty depressing
most new ideas will fail in the market
the second one gets even more depressing
even if competently executed now if
you've been around the block you know
that through most new ideas most new
companies most new products from
existing companies will fail in the
market right the data is you know you
cannot fight against it but what about
the second part what does it mean that
we fail even if competently executed it
means that even if you are in Google and
you launch products that are squarely
and what Google is good at the law of
market failure applies to you if you
search for Google failure one of the
pages you'll come up with is called the
Google graveyard apparently put together
by a Microsoft product manager who was
kind of upset at Google at the time and
but it illustrates that even large
companies fail a lot ask my students
take a piece of paper write all the
Google products you know of and then I
show them the list of the failures that
I know of and the ratio is usually five
or ten to one by the way the Google
Google didn't like what Microsoft did to
us so we created the Microsoft morgue
which has even more failed products
right so this is pretty much par for the
course you know the law of failure
applies to everybody but then I started
to say ok no failure is true I'm gonna
obey but why do most new ideas fail in
the market so I did my research look at
thousands of failure and basically put
them into three major buckets with a
convenient acronym flop failure due to
launch operation or premise failure due
to launch means that the market doesn't
know about your ID or cannot reach your
idea so essentially kind of a failure of
marketing people don't know about it
failure due to operation means the
product doesn't work right the app
crashes or maybe it's a restaurant and
the food sucks failure due to premise
means that even if you are
well even if it works well people simply
do not care about your new product idea
which one do you think is the most
common source of failure well I'll hold
the suspense it's the last one most new
ideas failed because the market simply
does not care and as we'll see even if
they tell you yes yes build it we will
buy it that's not the case most new
ideas fail because they are not what I
call the right it which happens to be
the title of my new book what is the
right it well I'll explain it in a
second but first the second important
strategy make sure you're building the
right it before you build it right
because all of my research and anybody
that's been around will confirm it
companies do not fail because they
really cannot build what they set out to
build I mean it happens but it's rare
most of the time you fail because you
built the wrong product so they write it
I define it as follows it's an idea that
if competently executed will succeed in
the market and it has an evil twin
the wrong it and at the end that even if
competently executed will fail in the
market it means that if your ideas bad
doesn't matter how much marketing
fireworks or engineering brilliance you
put into it it will fail in the market
let me give some examples of the right
it in the wrong gate Big Mac for
McDonnell they write it other arch
deluxe or the Mac hula a burger with a
slice of pineapple in the middle not the
right it right coca-cola the right it
New Coke after millions of dollars in
research and launched an advertising
failed not the right it everybody here
has probably seen the movie star wars
how many saw the movie Howard the Duck
not a lot yeah this is just a few and
you know what those two movies have in
common
Steven Spielberg Howard the Duck believe
it or not is a movie the Steven
Spielberg decided to do after Star Wars
and it had ten times the budget and on
top of it it had ducks and everybody
loves duck right Donald Duck Daffy Duck
that cool orange ducks are cool and yet
it failed miserably
Gmail how many people here have Gmail
account good how many people here had a
Google Wave account just pure hands yes
sir how many Google waves did you write
none right so you should actually you're
better the moment people said to write
so good Google Wave was supposed to be
the follow-up to email a new paradigm
lots of marketing developed by the same
people that did Google Maps
greet him and yet it failed and yet you
see it has the same Google call or the
same Google great engineer the free
massager the free lunches all the Google
benefits and yet it failed Ford Mustang
success for that so not so much right so
all of this what all of this example
what they have in common is that these
are companies that are successful with
other products and they're launching
products that are exactly what they do
like cars you know electronic things
movies and yet they fail because you
cannot fight the law of failure if you
take competent execution plus an idea
that is the wrong it you're guaranteed
failure 100% of the time the law of
failure is blind so you don't want to
bring out an idea that is the wrong gate
and you ask yourself well how do I know
if I'm an idea is they write it well do
not ask and what I mean by that is that
if all you have is an idea and you tell
other people your idea the most you can
get back are questions and this is a
very dangerous thing to do why because
ideas live in a place are called thought
land so in total you have an idea hey
here's my brilliant idea you tell it to
other people or what do you get back
this is a bunch of opinions oops I over
clicked a bunch of opinions and opinions
are subjective they are biased you know
you filter them through your own
preferences and beliefs I for example I
thought that uber was a terrible idea
strangers picking up strangers from
strange places and driving them to spend
the night at a stranger's house on the
couch
that's another startup idea Airbnb which
I thought was terrible right so you need
to
these ideas to horrible things happen in
thotland the first one is if you have an
idea and people think is the greatest
thing ever one of my favorite example is
the Segway transporter you know those
little scooters that you used to see few
years ago when this was about to be
launched everybody talked about it right
everybody thought best idea ever it was
in the cover of magazines that some of
the best pieces in the valley architects
said cities will be redesigned so
everybody's going around in a scooter
right so and then they launched it and
who do you see riding segways mall cups
and lazy tourists that's about it right
so and clearly it's not because a
failure due to marketing people knew
about it in fact it was talked all over
it's not a failure due to operation
because you work well I don't know why
things fail right I just know that most
of them fail so and these are called an
example of a false positive people tell
you best idea ever you launch it and it
fails how common are false positive the
most common thing that people launch so
everything in the Google graveyard in
the mattress of morgue in the Amazon
ambulance etcetera etcetera
all of these are ideas that at some
point people thought best ideas ever
and then they launched it and it failed
why because you know what doesn't fail
the law of market failure right most new
ideas will fail even in market if
competently executed so first bad thing
that happens people give you the thumbs
up you spend a lot of money you launch
idea it feels miserably the opposite can
happen you have an idea and people think
is the worst idea ever
honestly I felt that way about Twitter
the first time I heard about it what
hundred forty characters people can
follow everyone can follow anyone sounds
terrible and yet for better or worse we
know the twitter has changed the way
that we you know converse as a species
so this is an example of a false
negative people tell you it's a terrible
idea and then it succeeds so here's your
dilemma right if all you have is an idea
you cannot depend on people's opinion
you cannot just ask them would you want
it would you buy what would you do with
it so what can you depend on any ideas
okay well I'll tell you I'll jump ahead
cause we don't have a lot of time you
depend on data and as you can see you
trust your opinion trusts data and not
just any data your own data records
gonna tell people you know you need data
bits opinion and you need to collect
your data people think okay yeah well
this looks like data I mean it's in a
spreadsheet so it must be data no right
this two types of data
OPD and Yoda OPD stands for other
people's data
can you guess what your the stands for
thank you you guys are smart okay you're
great yes your own data and these two
are as different in my book literally as
apples and oranges in fact rotten apples
and fresh oranges OPD is the worst
possible thing you can collect right so
OPD is market data collected by other
people at all the time for other
products with other methods with other
filters etc etc it may or may not apply
to you and most of the time it does not
apply to you it's dangerous because just
because other ideas similar to yours are
failed doesn't mean that yours will fail
imagine if Elon Musk thinking of Tesla
thought well let me see how other car
companies did with electric cars you
know zero of them succeed I said well
okay forget this desert I think I'm
gonna go and do something else right so
just because other companies failed with
the n idea doesn't mean that you will
fail the opposite is true just because
other have succeeded in the past with
your idea doesn't mean that yours will
succeed Apple succeeded with the iPhone
Google succeeded with Android and
Samsung did Amazon succeed with the fire
phone no right
so OPD is very dangerous so I urge all
my intrapreneurs to collect your own
market data firsthand fresh local recent
recently collected and most importantly
your data needs to have skin in the game
what do I mean by skin in the game if I
asked you what do you think of my idea
and you tell me Oh Albert is good I said
should I leave my job to pursue it as a
sure go go for it right
you have nothing at risk skin in the
game means that as an intrapreneur
you're putting your risking right you're
risking your time your reputation your
money to go and start a new venture
you're putting your own skin in the game
you want to get skin in the game back
from the market right in skinning the
game can be the market's time money
commitment information repetition
something of value at risk let me give
you a very simple example Susie came up
with a great idea a smart hammer so you
you hit the nail instead of hitting your
fingers she goes and ask people hey and
I'm thinking of this hammer would you
buy it and some people said yes good
idea other people say bad idea
does this count us data no right this is
opinions now in another scenario she
says well I'm planning to build a summer
and if you give me $50 deposit I will
make sure that you get one of the first
one so some people say it's a lame idea
they're dead to me you know just like in
short time
you're dead to me but the other people
say instead of saying it's a good idea
if they actually open their wallet and
give you some money
you have the first indication that the
market really is interested in your idea
right you fix an asymmetry before you
put in your skin in the game but
quitting your job or getting VC funding
get some from the market so that's what
we call Yoda you can quote me on this
it's much easier to get people to open
their mouth than to open their wallet
the hardest thing an entrepreneur can do
is to get companies and people to open
their wallet I've been told so many
times Alberto it's a fantastic idea go
build it and then when I went to sell it
to them say well yeah not to not we're
having a bad quarter forget about it
right so it's very important you need to
change the way you approach market
research from this traditional model of
doing market surveys or asking people
this question if we build it will you
buy it which is how most market research
is done by the way right you you ask
these questionnaires you flip it around
completely 180 degrees think about this
if you buy it we will build it now this
seems very counterintuitive but I will
give you example of how exactly how to
do it because now you're asking well
don't have to have a product built
before I can see if people want to buy
and the answer is no you don't build it
you pretotype it this is not a topper
this is a word I invented pretotype it
because it had
to be invented so strategy number five
is pretotype it what is the pretotype
well it's the simplest artifact or
technique you can use to collect yura
very quickly and very inexpensively so
there is a big range between having an
at the end the final product this could
be years months you know a millions of
dollars and the way I said pretotype
come very very early
if pretotype is something that you can
build in minutes hours maybe a couple of
days and it should cost anywhere from
zero to maybe a couple of hundred bucks
if you really feel like splurging right
a prototype is something that actually
works can do something and can take a
couple of days couple weeks couple of
months I've worked on prototypes for
software development tools that took a
year and a half just to prove that the
thing would actually work and of course
the products take a long time so printer
types are things that you can build very
very quickly literally in a couple of
hours let me give you an example of
pretotyping something they actually got
my thinking about this process about 34
years ago IBM wanted to everybody to
have personal computers but you know
four years ago most people didn't know
how to type right those of us that were
around there you remember this how
people tap so this figured no way that
people can use computers they have to
learn how to type who types programmers
writers and secretaries right nobody
else knows how to type nobody wants to
take typing lessons but they wanted to
know well if we solve this problem of
speech-to-text
right so you can just speak to a
computer will people actually buy our
product so they did something very
clever an experiment they brought people
in the room they giving them at a
microphone a monitor no keyboard until
the look speaking to this computer we
have a prototype of speech-to-text and
people spoke into it and magically the
computer did whatever people told them
to do of course this was not possible
those days even the fastest computer
couldn't handle this so what was
happening well in a room next door one
of those amazing people that can tap as
fast as you can talk was actually
transcribing everything that was being
heard through the computer and I tell
you as an engineer this example kind of
really messed up with my mind because if
you go in how many engineers here
yeah I mean the use soldering iron
etcetera so if you come to an engineer
said Alberto we need to build a
prototype I said great
fire up the compiler or the soldering
error right I thought this is not a
prototype they're just pretending that
they have something to work so in fact
that created this first word pretend
o-type because I knew this is not a
prototype is not like IBM was planning
to breed a race of small type is that
they fit inside boxes and you feed them
cheese and crackers through the floppy
drive right so it's not a prototype this
is something completely different from
the end product and then I Shrunk the
world to pretotype because it's easier
to pronounce but remember pretotype
means before a prototype but also use
your imagination to pretend so what IBM
learned is that before the prototype
tests a lot of people thought of course
we want a speech-to-text computer now if
you try to actually use a speech-to-text
computer all day with our keyboard your
throat gets sore the room gets very loud
and you cannot dictate or work on
confidential things like fire Bob oh
sorry Bob didn't know you were around
here right so in toplin speech-to-text
was a sure winner when people actually
tried it realize it was not so this is
an example of what I call a Mechanical
Turk prototype you know in disease
everybody's talking about robotics and
AI before you spend four years and 40
million dollars to create some automated
pizza maker or something something else
you can use human beings to simulate
that behavior it doesn't scale but you
can learn if people would actually use
it a prototype we don't know it's
something you usually typically build to
figure out can we build it how long will
the battery last how will it work etc
etc it basically asks the question how
do we build it right and here's the
secret most of the time you can build it
now if you tell me I have an idea for a
time machine you know I call the guys
with the white coats and tell you you
probably cannot build it but most of the
ideas people have are buildable a
prototype asks different question it
asked you should we build it you know
will I use it what will I use it for
in other words pretotype asked the idea
it asked is this idea the right it
something that if I built competently
will succeed in the market now there are
several prototyping techniques is a
cheat sheet from a class
the honour of teaching with Tina let me
give you just a few more example the
facade Prototype cars Dirac wanted to
know at the beginning of the internet
with people buy used cars online so what
did they do did the buy cars that have a
bit complicated website now that a very
simple website with just a few cars no
cars in inventory they advertise it and
miraculously the first two days the sold
for car so immediately the shut down the
website they bought four cars are
retailed they sold them at retail so the
lost a few hundred dollars on each car
but what did the gain know that right
Yoda nothing is more valuable than a
check right a check tells you that
people really want your product I'd
rather have a one-page business plan an
outline with four checks staple to it
then a 30 page highly detailed business
plan with all kinds of charts another
example of pretotyping is this from Ikea
this team in San Francisco came up with
a really simple protocol the wall hub
it's a piece of plastic where you put
your keys and your mail they wanted to
know would people buy them you know
should we have ten thousand built so
that then idea they thought well where
would people buy this IKEA so they did
something very clever
they went on eBay that you they bought
they use a kia employee sure so they
could pretend remember pretended happy
that they were an IKEA employee then
they created a fake label for their
product of course had to change it to a
Nakia name like Val hub and they put
this label and then instead of
shoplifting they entered the Nakia store
and place their product on some free
shelf space and then they watch to see
if anybody would actually stop and buy
it and lo and behold you can watch the
video I put the link there people
actually took it put it in their cart
and everything worked fine until they
got to the cashier because things got a
little confusing but would you agree
that if I have two valve hubs in my cart
is that opinion know that other people
didn't oh that's Yura that's the most
valuable thing you can have another
example of pretotyping called the
impersonator you can take an existing
product put a wrapper around it and very
quickly come up with a new idea and then
you can use that to collect data my
favorite example for this is what Elon
Musk did with the original Tesla
Roadster you took a
Lotus Elise ripped off the the gasoline
engine put an electric engine and then
went you know built this one-off model
and then gave people rides in this car
it's amazing zero to 60 in three seconds
so let's assume I gave you for a ride
did you like it quickly quickly did you
like yes pretty fast and sex okay it's
going to cost $120,000 and you have to
wait two years and you have to put it to
the big charge in your garage would you
buy it okay so two years and two no so
the nose are dead to me now
but the yes have not given me any skin
in the game so what Ilyn muster to which
was brilliant to say remember if you buy
it I will build it so I'm gonna ask you
well you know it's not that I don't
trust you guys but you know if you give
me a check for $5,000 out putting them
in the list you're number 31 you're
number 32
nothing is it easier to say yes or to
write a check for $5,000 to a guy that
never built a car company before right
and yet 300 people did that into these
days you cannot buy a Tesla without
putting a deposit so if you think that
my idea if you buy it we will build it
is crazy Tesla is a perfect example of
that in action you want to do this
because you want to fail fast and cheap
people talk a lot about failing fast but
as you can tell from how fast I speak
that's not fast enough for me
right I tell tell them I want you to
fail very fast and Fiat chip
sorry fear right so because remember
most new ideas will fail in the market
which means that you have to test a lot
of ideas and if you take six months to
test and ideas good luck right unless
your luck is going to take forever so
pretotyping allows you to test very
quickly more importantly you're not
going to experience painful failure
records you spend $20 to do an expert to
do a a preview path test it's an
experiment right it doesn't hurt
definitely doesn't hurt after as much as
spending three years and twenty five
million dollars to build the product
that that that people do not want so
strategy number six say it with numbers
entrepreneurs and probably most of you
when the oven idea you come to me and
you you express it very vaguely so
here's an idea from some of your fellow
students maybe five six years ago
second a sushi
here's the idea right packet sushi is
kind of expensive so they thought you
know what if we buy sushi that's about
to expire right it's only good for an
extra eight hours before it kills you
we can buy for twenty-five cents on the
dollars and sell it at fifty cents on
the dollars and since students are young
and have a strong stomach we can handle
it
so I said okay I'm not gonna give my
opinion on your idea but but I'm asking
them so this is how they articulated
right people lots of them will buy not
super fresh sushi if it's cheap enough
that's pretty much how the expresses it
look who are these people
how many is lost and what is cheap
enough so I I was in a room actually
outside there you know just outside this
auditorium and somebody left a formulas
you know calculus class or electrical
engineering class on the on the wall and
I thought okay tell you what
write it like this X percent of Y we'll
see I call this the X Y Z hypothesis
right so it forces you to write your
idea in numbers so in this case they
translate it into number twenty percent
of packaged sushi buyers will buy second
the sushi if it's half the price of
fresher sushi
how do you know if those numbers are
right you don't it's a hypothesis right
but at least it articulates and puts
into number what your ideas are and what
is the job of a hypothesis a hypothesis
exists to be tested and pretotyping or
tool to test hypothesis last point test
think global test local maybe the second
a sushi team is planning to take over
the market right every supermarket is
going to have second a sushi but you
need to start to test your ideas very
quickly you want to minimize this
metrics that are explained in my book
called time today that dollars to data
distance to data if peoples have this
great at the end and it's six months two
million dollars and I need to fly to
Hawaii to do my research I said well no
you're gonna do it here you're going to
do it for twenty dollars and I want the
results by tomorrow right and a
technique for doing that is called hypo
zooming so you take this big hypothesis
twenty percent of packaged sushi buyers
and you zoom in you know you know those
documentaries where you see or those
videos where you see the Earth from
space and then it zooms in to a you know
to a town and then to a particular
place and then to a building I want you
to do that in your mind right so you
take the big XYZ hypothesis and hyper
zoom to something you can test here and
now I'm gonna say here and now I mean it
literally here and now right so where
are we now
North America right we're in North
America Silicon Valley
we're in Silicon Valley Stanford
University we're in Stanford University
building y2e - and then ask you is there
a place in this building or nearby that
sells sushi yes there is absurd right
Cooper cafes just said great so you're
gonna hypo zoom you can you have your
market it small sample of your market is
there so you can go from the big xoc
hypothesis to the small XYZ hypothesis
20% of students buying sushi Cooper cafe
- that dinner will buy secondly sushi
right and do you believe that this is
actually testable can I do this test
absolutely in fact we did it we even did
a little video why would some of my
friends there is where are you guys yes
we did it here we we filmed it we went
we created little labels that said
second a sushi half off and we slapped
them on fresh sushi right it's an
impersonator pretotype and then we try
to sell them in fact if you're there
that's outside the stvp offices now how
many people do you think bought our
second a sushi zero is right right
because they ain't on the typical thing
is well you know I don't want to get
sick so doesn't mean that second the
sushi has no chance it just means that
you need to do some more tests but
frankly your your that doesn't look very
good right so these are just seven
strategies there's a lot more but I
cannot possibly talk any faster and our
time is limited so there is more yes a
lot more there is a book I see some of
you already bought it
thank you so much if you haven't voted
go to Amazon and buy it now I'm not done
yes it's it's a great book thank you but
there is more
but because the question you have to ask
is hey Alberto do you practice what you
teach say you better do not because I
don't want to be a hypocrite because
what I teach works all the techniques
are I'm an engineer I'm not in marketing
I'm not in sale I'm an engineer if it
doesn't work I wouldn't talk about it
right so three toe-tapping techniques
cannot not work any more that the
quadratic formula can not work right you
plug in the numbers unless you scrub it
does work so I thought most books fail
in the market they don't even find the
publisher so before doing that I spent a
few days
less than a week writing a pretotype
book called pretotyping
I printed in PDF I made it available I
stapled some copies myself soon tens of
thousands of people started to download
it translated into a dozen languages so
I thought I was able to find a publisher
they said okay this looks promising so I
actually went from the prototype to a
prototype which in the case of a book is
a first draft and then it finally became
the product so very one of the many
examples of me practicing what I preach
with that I think we'll just write good
on time and thank you so much
[Applause]